bienvenue dans l'entretien de france 24
notre invité se définit comme arabe et
française occidentale et orientale
musulmane et laïque femme et écrivain et
de rajouter tant de choses encore qui ne
se disent pas elle est née en algérie il
ya 66 ans vit et travaille depuis plus
de 40 ans en france ou l art of où il a
étudié le droit et les sciences
politiques mais c'est au questionnement
spirituel qu'elle consacre la plupart de
ses oeuvres merci karima berger de nous
rejoindre sur france 24
merci merci à vous alors on vous reçoit
pour ce magnifique ouvrage les
gardiennes du secret consacrée aux
grandes figures féminines de
l'imaginaire musulmans publié chez albin
michel alors avant d'entrer dans le
détail du livre parlez nous de vous vous
dites que vous êtes né dans une famille
où les femmes ne lisait pas vous n'êtes
pas théologienne comment définissez vous
votre rapport à l'islam
mon rapport à l'islam est un rapport ce
tir est normal
qu'ils datent de l'enfance l'islam pour
moi et comme le berceau dans lequel je
suis né c'est ma langue c'est mon
imaginaire c'est ma façon de rêver de
penser le monde
et j'ai eu envie un moment d'aller
creuser d'aller voir ce qu'il en était
de façon concrète et pas seulement
d'entendre ce qui se dit sur l'islam je
suis rentré c'est à dire que j'ai lu le
coran et je me souviens toujours de ce
premier jour où j'avais 20 ans en
algérie et où j'ai acheté mon premier
corps en 2cv les corans de mon père qui
était enfermé dans dans la bibliothèque
bien à l'abri et le jour où j'ai acheté
mon premier qu'orange avait l'impression
que c'était un acte je me demandais même
si je pouvais me autorisée voyez alors
bien sûr je les jeux les enveloppes et
d'un très joli satin rose et s'est
exclamé est ce que j'ai le droit de le
lire moi même et j'avais un débat avec
ma mère qui disait toujours là riceys
l'alizé un commentaire du coran je dis
mais pourquoi tu vas pas direct au texte
ouais ça la vraie question alors direct
au texte et vous interrogé dans ce livre
le pouvoir des femmes le titre
d'ailleurs et énigmatique et gardienne
du secret qui attise la curiosité a
véritablement ce secret et vous en
parlait en citant notamment le verset 34
qui a été longtemps vous dites que c'est
l'adn de la misogynie coranique
longtemps mal traduit comment justement
vous en êtes arrivé à cette découverte
c'est étonnant jeu dans cette lecture
quasi quotidiennes et je tombe sur ce
membre de verser de la sonatt nice à la
sourate des femmes nature à 2,4 et je
tombe sur ce bout de verser qui est
enchâssé vraiment d'en inverser assez
juridique voilà et puis au milieu vous
trouvez les femmes vertueuses mais nous
sommes tout vertueuse
plein de dépositions plein pieuse sont
les gardiennes du secret de ce que dieu
garde secret en arabe c'est face à
l'eire est à flux atom lille raised by
may a fait d'armes là en fait en arabe
c'est le rêve c'est le mystère c'est la
chose la plus mystérieuse qu'on ne peut
pas dire qu'on ne peut pas définir qu'on
ne peut pas décrire mais je voulais pas
écrire le livre avec le titre les femmes
du mystère ça fait trop ésotérique
et le secret aussi c'est une chose
mystérieuse voilà et donc ce verset
donc je suis tombé je suis tombé de ma
chaise parce que je trouvais qu'il était
magnifique les femmes sont les
gardiennes du secret de ce que deux
gains de secret vous ne savez pas ce que
c'est que ce secret mais vous savez que
ce sont les femmes qui en ont la garde
et peut être elles mêmes ne savent pas
quel est ce secret mais comment est il
traduit jusqu alors alors à présent
d'ailleurs oui mes textes oui tout à
fait alors les traductions je cite je
crois une quinzaine et sur la quinzaine
de traduction il y en a une dizaine qui
disent ceci les femmes vertueuses
dévotion aux pleins de dévotion sont les
gardiennes de leur corps de leur pudeur
pendant l'absence de leur mari ainsi que
le leur a demandé comment des hommes là
alors qu'ils font quand vous le lisez en
arabe littéralement vous ne trouvez pas
de mari vous ne trouvez pas d'absence
rape ça peut être l'absent fc c'est
l'absence divine enfin c'est pas
l'absence divine mais c'est c'est
l'absence de représentations dieu c'est
ça c'est en aucun cas une dimension
banda marie absolument les hommes ont
rajouté le mari assez incroyable et
voilà ils ont rajouté le mari absent ils
ont rajouté la pudeur ils ont rajouté le
fait qu'elles doivent garder leur sexe
alors qu'il ya un autre verset plus loin
qui dit oh vous et les hommes et les
femmes
gardez votre sexe et à baisser votre
regard tous les deux oui voyez moi il
public tous les deux voilà soyez public
tous les deux et là donc ils se sont
lâchés ils en ont profité pour rien
faire mais dans la tradition mais dans
la tradition musulmane quand vous
demandez à musulmans qu'est ce que
signifie ce verset et bien vous dise la
femme doit garder sa chasteté son corps
sans aller dans ce sens absent de ce
grand bal qu'on paie quoi la saison et
alors justement parmi les exemples parce
que là on en vient au coeur du livre des
figures féminines il y en a plusieurs à
on pourrait citer fatima la fille du
prophète on pourrait citer rabia el
éliminé enfin salit la poétesse on
pourrait en citer d'autres mais
j'aimerais qu'on parle de khadija qui
est la première khadija qui est la
première musulmane fectivement la
première épouse du prophète qui n'est
pas comptabilisée comme tel dans
l'historiographie classique musulmane tu
as fait ce qui est quand même étonnant
aussi parce que c'est quand même elle
qui
la première a cru en lui
le prophète mohamed revenait de c2c nuit
de retraite et de prières et et il
revenait en dix ans meurt khadija je
suis je suis en 3 soit un démon soit un
non je ne sais pas est ce que tu peux
m'aider est ce que tu peux me dire et la
femme elle va le prendre contre lui je
vais pas raconter l'histoire en détail
mais il faut raconter ça se trouve dans
la zone à où il a fait donc elle le met
contre lui et il dit est ce que tu vois
encore cette créature est il dit non il
dit tiens toi ferme cousin c'est bien un
ange qui vient de visiter ce n'est pas
un démon et c'est la première ainsi
qu'ils croient aaa
à la révélation duo messager ou en fait
voilà du prophète mohamed et elle a été
aussi une femme assez extraordinaire
parce qu'elle a la finance et toute la
campagne de l'islam elle était une très
riche caravanières on pourrait dire
aujourd'hui une femme manager elle a été
et pourtant dans l'histoire quand on
voit le premier musulman on pense à ali
on dit allez alléger tout le respect
pour lui le le khalife malheureux qui
n'a pas pu accéder tout de suite à la
succession du prophète et
alice était son cousin c'était vraiment
un intime du prophète m'entendre
vraiment n'engendre ensuite tout à fait
et mais c'est pour lui je suis désolé
c'est déjà ça khadija sermersheim voilà
c'est le secret absolu mort parce
qu'elle a su pardon sur le secret ella
ella elle sait d'où elle sert hadidja du
l6 comment elle a su comment immanente
koala de façon émanant d'une espèce de
de savoir insu qui n'est pas savoir
académique ont un savoir deux allées ou
de savants ou de quelque chose d'une
sensibilité qui va peut-être nous
conduire à la définition du féminin mais
justement vous dit qu il y aurait
presque un malentendu ans dans l'islam
entre les femmes l'islam un cruel
paradoxe les femmes sont victimes de sa
entre coincé entre un féminin
magnifier au plan spirituel et la misère
finalement au plan social et historique
comment vous expliquer oui c'est c'est
vraiment cruel parce que je pense que
cet acte de khadija qui a investi
finalement pourrait dire qu'elle a
investi le prophète puisqu'elle la la
elle a reconnu qu'il y avait là une
révélation divine le fait qu'elle sache
quelque chose peut-être a été l'occasion
pour les hommes et la société
patriarcale il faut bien se souvenir
c'est quand même
l'arabie du 7e siècle c'est quand même
des temps extrêmement éloignée et des
des temps avec des moeurs assez assez
durs assez sauvage même et le fait que
cette femme sache peut-être que
les hommes se sont dit mais ces femmes
elles savent quelque chose et il faut
peut-être les protéger mettre à part il
faut sauvegarder la puissance qu'elles
ont de savoir
d'ailleurs que madame du prophète vous
expliquer ne seront pas mariée à la mort
du prophète mais alors parlons juste
rapidement en creux vous parlez aussi
des hommes évidemment on est des hommes
dans la société arabo-musulmane et en
particulier en particulier et vous dit
que finalement il y aurait une virilité
un tranquille de coire est ce que parler
justement les appelle les gardiens un
tranquille oui parce que en fait ce
livre c'est vrai que j'ai voulu exim et
sortir de la poussière toutes ces femmes
qui ont été recouvertes de tradition de
loi etc mais je pense aussi beaucoup
d'hommes de l'islam je pense que ses
hommes dans cette société
je pense qu'ils sont malheureux aussi je
pense qu'ils ont une autre forme de
d'oppression quelque chose qui pèse sur
leurs épaules sur leurs épaules et
notamment ce devoir de virilité ce
devoir de montrer qu'ils sont qui sont
les chefs qui sont les mâles qu'ils
peuvent tuer comme disait germaine qui
ont les matamores il m'a vivement mettre
à mort et c'est terrible ça d'avoir en
permanence et jeudi un moment je pense
que c'est que dans dans l'intimité avec
leurs femmes que les hommes peuvent
déposer les armes et peuvent retrouver
quelque chose du féminin quelques choses
de l'amour quelque chose de
pas ce que dieu sait comme un jackman
c'est quand même
un des plus beaux noms de dieu c'est le
miséricordieux varma c'est un nom arabe
et qui veut dire la matrice les
entrailles donc on dit il aime ces
créatures comme une mère ses enfants et
le fait que
et le fait que ouais ne soient pas à
leur jouer là bas et on comprend pas ce
paradoxe c'est vraiment vraiment et ben
karima berger merci infiniment d'être
venu nous présenter votre dernier
ouvrage les gardiennes du secret j'en
profite pour évidemment
vous intime ou proposer de lire d'autres
ouvrages de karima berger merci d'être
venus je rappelle ce titre de ce
magnifique ouvrage les gardiennes du
secret vous saurez tout vous découvrirez
tout sur les grandes figures féminines
trop oublié de l'imaginaire public
musulman c'est publiés chez albin-michel
cours et si vous en prie n'hésitez pas
et reste avec nous car l'actualité
continue sur france 24
[Musique]